yesterday as i've been following the
terrible situation in texas
because of a winter storm people lacking
power some lacking heat
and more i came across a ted cruz
tweet that i found suspicious this is
republican
texas senator ted cruz who tweeted quote
today senator john cornyn and i sent a
letter
to president biden urging for governor
abbott's emergency federal disaster
declaration request
to be approved amid severe winter storms
across the state of texas now when i saw
this i had an
inkling that wait a second i remember
ted cruz in the past
when the natural disasters were in some
other part of the country that he
doesn't represent
i remember ted being against disaster
declarations
and federal money for the affected
states
so i went back into the tdps archives
and found that yes ted cruz really is a
disgusting hypocrite on this issue
back in 2012 when hurricane sandy
ravaged the northeast of the united
states states like new york and new
jersey
ted cruz voted against providing federal
aid
to those northeast states why did he
vote against it well he said that the
bill was symptomatic of spending money
we don't have
in washington dc but then in 2015
when there were floods in texas ted cruz
wanted federal money
for them and then in 2017
when hurricanes hit texas suddenly ted
cruz wanted federal money for texas
for that and this actually came up on
msnbc back in 2017. check this out
but a lot of people are pointing out
that you voted against
aid for sandy after that catastrophic
catastrophic storm
up in the northeast that package back in
2012.
and they're they're pointing at you and
saying you're asking for money now when
you weren't willing to help the people
in the northeast what do you have to say
to them
well you know look there's time for
political sniping
later i think our focus needs to be on
this crisis
that's right it isn't political sniping
it's a pretty simple question
of it appears that you can be counted on
to push for money for disaster relief
for your state but to stand in the way
of similar monies for non-constituents
and eventually ted cruz gives an answer
it's a completely bogus one these are
people who needed money and who needed
funding right after that storm i covered
those people
many of them just like those in houston
lost absolutely
everything they owned
well katie katie of course that's right
and and the accurate thing to say is
that i and a number of others
enthusiastically and emphatically
supported hurricane relief
for sandy hurricane relief and disaster
relief has been a
vital federal role for a long long time
and it should continue
the problem with that particular bill is
it became a 50 billion dollar bill
that was filled with unrelated pork
two-thirds of that bill had nothing to
do with sandy
and and what i said then and still
believe now is is that it's not right
for politicians to exploit
a disaster and people are hurting to pay
for their own political wish list
disaster relief needs to be focused on
the victims of disaster relief and i
supported that
for sandy disaster relief there and i
would support that anywhere there's a
major disaster
without getting getting distracted by by
political unnecessary pork spending
oh that bill had pork i okay i
see he's disgusting and in fact
politifact
looked at this and it's a talking point
that republicans
often used in their in defending their
opposition
to funding relief for hurricane sandy
some of them would say
50 of the 60 billion in that bill is
pork or
two-thirds of it is pork or 90 of it is
pork but the truth is that it was all
lies now
it's not actually exactly clear how much
of the bill
from 2012 was specifically
for disaster relief for sandy because
there was money in there
for mitigation of future disasters
and as usual there is some pork but
that's business as usual that has
nothing to do with
where the disaster is that's sadly how
congress works
it's horrible but it's many of ted
cruz's own republican colleagues
who were responsible for a bunch of that
pork being in the 2012 bill
but here's the key thing um when you
talk about
disaster relief it should be part of it
to prepare for the next one when we talk
about coronavirus now
and the package that democrats now want
to get through it includes money for
rebuilding
some of the infrastructure that donald
trump destroyed getting rid of the
pandemic response team
throwing out the playbook all of these
different things if we don't
take steps to harden and make systems
more robust
this is just going to happen again and
the idea that that's why ted cruz voted
against it is absolutely insane now let
me be super clear
i don't want to punish people of texas
because ted cruz is a hypocrite
i want the people of texas to get the
money
i just want ted cruz not to oppose
disaster relief
when it comes to some other state but
defiantly defend it
when it's his own state that's what's
pathetic here and ted cruz has a long
history of doing this
many republicans have a lot you know we
we're we're talking about ted cruz now
because he's involved in this because
it's his state now
but the same thing happened in i'm i'm
going from memory here but i believe it
was
in oklahoma because of tornadoes
when there were republicans that were
saying of course we need the declaration
in oklahoma we need the federal relief
money in oklahoma they had voted against
sandy relief
in 2012 for new york and new jersey um
i believe tennessee i mean we'd have to
look at the full list but this is a type
of hypocrisy
that is not rare in the american right
and it's absolutely destructive ted cruz
is as disgusting as the rest of them
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself by being able to soak up an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
i recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by daniel rolls
and kieran rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what i'm
doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27 different non-fiction categories and
a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video